si la asamblea nacional aprobó nuevas
medidas restrictivas en francia- al
cierre de escuelas y la extensión del
confinamiento en toda la francia
metropolitana durante cuatro semanas
este jueves se anunciaron nuevas
restricciones en lo que se considera un
rompecabezas el 'toque de queda' irá de
siete de la tarde a seis de la mañana se
prohíben viajes entre departamentos y se
deben justificar las salidas a una
distancia superior a 10 kilómetros desde
el domicilio los comercios no esenciales
estarán cerrados y se podrá impedir el
acceso a exteriores propicios
aglomeraciones
además se prohíbe beber alcohol en la
calle y se pedirá a las fiscalías la
persecución de fiestas ilegales estas
últimas medidas con el fin de que no se
repitan imágenes como las del carnaval
ilegal de marsella de hace unas semanas
quiero ante ustedes condenar sin tapujos
la irresponsabilidad mostrada por
algunos ciudadanos creyéndose
invencibles a los estragos de la
enfermedad
a pesar de aprobarse las medidas es una
de las votaciones más tensas que se
recuerdan la oposición realizó un boicot
masivo a la votación con 220
abstenciones derecha e izquierda
critican la falta de consensos en una
pandemia que consideran que ha sido
hiper presidencial este es realmente el
día de los inocentes y la broma del día
es esta ridícula pantomima enmascarado
escuchó al presidente macro
felicitándose por haber esperado el
mayor tiempo posible es espera déjenme
decirlo con toda la seriedad fue
irresponsable
la tercera ola en francia tiene las ucis
desbordadas y un promedio de 40.000
casos diarios sin embargo el primer
ministro castex aseguró que mantienen la
previsión de celebrar elecciones
regionales en junio mes en el que macro
dijo que esperan haber vacunado a 30
millones de franceses